a great photograph can make someone
change their mind people don't know what
they don't know they have their
preconceived ideas they'll form an
opinion of something that they've never
really encountered and sometimes if a
picture is powerful enough it can take
them there it can change their minds you
might get one in your lifetime but it's
worth working your whole life to make
that one picture a bet they want this
story and we can we can talk while I'm
out there my name is Katie orlinsky and
I'm a photographer the first time I
picked up a camera was when I was around
14 and it was a birthday present from my
father and I loved it it was a Pentax I
would shoot black and white they were
pictures of like a man sitting next to a
statue like you know 14 15 year old
person art it took me a really long time
to figure out my own voice to figure out
the stories that I was best at telling I
don't fit into a box of a photographer I
photograph so many different and diverse
stories I like to change my own mind
when I find a story that blows me away I
kind of assume that it will do the same
for other people
a lot of my photography has this one
thing in common I photograph people
living their lives with in extreme
situations I think these people are
interesting strong resilient my name is
Kristen pace and I'm a professional dog
musher that means that I raise and train
sled dogs and run thousand miles lead
dog races my husband Andy and I run hey
moose kennel we decided in 2011 we
wanted to start a sled dog team which is
just the most absurd undertaking of all
time we started with four dogs and now
we have thirty here in two weeks
you can't tell okay would you maybe use
your arm and lean on something I met
Katie last summer one of my best friends
had showed up to show us this litter of
puppies and out jumps Katie so it was
like hey look at all these puppies and
also there's like a National Geographic
photographer here all right so chin down
just a bit when I got my first
assignment in Alaska I had never even
heard of mushing and I had no idea what
the Edyta rod was which is sort of the
most famous dog sled race they race a
thousand miles across the Alaskan
wilderness somewhere between like
seventy and ninety teams it takes years
to build a team and to qualify for the
race you could be going through negative
60 you have to be completely
self-sufficient and run on little to no
sleep for about eight days
if any kind of like right here I've
covered the races as a whole in the past
but really it was a sports story it's
great for this story I'd like to focus
on Kristin who's going to be running her
first to dinner odd I'd really like to
tell the story of one person and what it
takes to run this race my goal is always
to capture intimate moments within these
extreme circumstances I think it's
really important to capture images that
make people feel something for the other
person that has a universal quality to
it because everybody loves and everybody
is devastated I want the photographs I
make to make people feel things because
when I'm taking them I'm feeling things
after experiences covering conflict and
losing friends I definitely became
pretty cynical and disillusioned I was
still shooting but my heart wasn't in it
i deep-down really hoped that it wasn't
forever and that something would come
around that got me going again and then
it did when I went out to velasca how
many dogs I'm just going to take eight
today cause it's so icy and yeah we're
gonna be stopping how it's gonna be
twice this long for the Iditarod nuts to
think about
[Music]
so the feeling of being out in the
middle of nowhere totally alone with the
dog team it's the ultimate test because
it's like every experience you've ever
had in your life and all of the training
you've ever done in your life has led
you to this moment and here you are and
there's no one here to reach out hand
and help you it is totally up to you to
get you and these 16 living things that
you love more than anything in the world
safely to the next spot on the map it
gets you to the root of yourself I think
that's why it's so addicting
[Music]
[Music]
yeah this is the probably the best photo
of the race love that mm-hmm
the thing that surprised me the most
about the mushers were how many female
mushers there were God she looks like a
badass yeah you made all of us not smile
I have some smiley photos whatever
whatever you're trying to make us all
look really tough you are really tough
are you nervous brother you dinner odd
I'm excited I can't wait to see the
ocean and be anxious to know that like
we got there from here we got all the
way to the ocean from here
[Music]
I think anybody that's obsessed with
something the way you have to be to be a
dog musher and it's not something that's
inspiring to me I relate to being
obsessed with stuff because that's kind
of how I get with my stories a lot of
the women mushers get asked what is it
like to be a woman musher riding the
Iditarod and it's kind of a crazy
question to get asked because it's
really the last thing any of us think
about you're just a dog musher what
matters is how good of a dog driver you
are and how good you are at surviving
and building a fire when you get wet and
coals no one cares if you have boobs
[Music]
it wasn't until going to Alaska where I
came to this realization that I can make
important work that still has a message
and inspires me and it doesn't have to
be sad it's nothing new to them but from
an outsider's perspective it's amazing
and I think it's something that would be
great for young girls all over the world
to see this sport that's co-ed that
women are kicking ass
[Music]
there's so much going on in the world
there's a lot of darkness but there's
also a lot of light and a lot of beauty
and I don't want everything that I
photograph to be about one or the other
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]